I'm not sure whether other people on the
ship would be happy but I look at other
people more I like to observe have a
look at what someone's wearing you know
imagine what sort of person there'd be
just try and live in the moment a bit
more that's right no Facebook no Twitter
no Instagram no whatsapp
[Music]
what triggered it was a breakup I think
when something like that happens you
need to just let someone die social
media death and just remove them from
your life and then I realized that
actually they were not useful to me
anyway so I just went the whole hog and
didn't bother using the member again the
point about social media is the
addictiveness nobody really wants to
spend hours and hours every day updating
their status and seeing what other
people think about them nobody
consciously wants to do that but those
behaviors are themselves addictive
behaviors what you're trapped in that
loop it's very hard to break out it's
not that we want to go back to some
until ik past and Eden before the
machines existed it's that we need to
take control of these machines and use
them for their proper ends the bad thing
is that you think people's lives is much
more fun than your own life when I'm the
boss I just see people like like zombies
and I'm like right there is a Sun it's a
sunny day there is no there is something
to see that's only your phone you know I
like to be present when I share
something about myself with someone so I
can get their feedback and either stop
right there or tell them the story
behind it or give context sometimes I
might withhold a certain opinion
kind of rapid-fire because maybe maybe
it requires a bit of nuance and maybe
the best thing is not for me to just
shoot my mouth off online because some
headline made me angry the thing is the
world is real whether we want to believe
it or not and it's really important for
us to have a sense of where we are in
that world I don't like to use the term
social media at the end of the day
because it implies that it's designed to
promote social behaviors when usually
it's designed to promote the amount of
attention that we're giving it in order
to grab our attention because there's so
much competition design has to appeal to
the lower parts of us to the kind of
non-rational automatic impulsive parts
of us and so this is why we get things
like clickbait like sensationalism
things that appeal to our outrage and
there's a whole industry of consultants
of psychologists who are are helping
designers really punch the right buttons
in our brains so that we we do keep
coming back for more and we do stay
hooked on the products you know the end
of the day their advertising system is
not really social platforms
[Music]
some of them take social media breaks
quite a lot anyway so it's not like I'm
doing something that's particularly
divergent but they think it's a good
thing I think they realize we all
realized that we look at memes too much
we use Instagram too much it's just
whether we realize that and do something
about it there are things that give us
you know instant pleasure and they're
like the more gluttonous things like
food and sex and stuff like that and
they give us a really high spike of
pleasure but the things that are the
most worthwhile and the things that you
spend a lot of time on so playing the
piano is not pleasant to begin with but
you gap I can much more steady wave of
satisfaction so it does matter because
the pleasures that are sometimes the
most time-consuming or the ones that
take the most work can be the ones that
are the most fulfilling those are their
pleasures that are self actualizing that
help you realize a part of yourself you
didn't have
[Applause]
I'm on it probably every day just to be
nosy and sure I could live without him
we did before didn't we